[Music]
Tucker Carlson tonight it is all but
official Elizabeth Warren is now the
Democratic frontrunner in a survey
released today by Quinnipiac University
in Connecticut Warren maintains a
seven-point lead over Joe Biden that's
the candidate all the people on
television assurance will be the
Democratic nominee Warren is a full 13
points ahead of Bernie Sanders now keep
in mind that both Warren and Sanders are
Northeastern socialists they're pulling
from essentially the same strain of
Democratic primary voters splitting that
vote should dramatically weakened
Warren's position in the field but she's
leading anyway that's how dominant she
is so unless something unforeseen and
dramatic happens between now and next
spring and it could but if it doesn't
Elizabeth Warren will be the Democratic
nominee and that as they say has
implications for all of us there her
many terrible policy ideas obviously
we'll get to those in just a minute but
more immediately there is one herself
you're gonna be seeing a lot of
Elizabeth Warren over the next year
she'll be on your television screen
non-stop you will hear her voice rising
from your car radio at red lights if you
live in Iowa New Hampshire or South
Carolina you may find her in the flesh
loitering outside your Starbucks or
waiting on your doorstep prepare
yourself because wherever there is
Elizabeth Warren there is falseness fake
is who Warren is she has authentically
ersatz
it turns out that they're pretending to
be an Indian is not the least real thing
Warren has ever done she is always that
synthetic even when she's sitting her
own kitchen hold on a second I'm gonna
get me my husband
it's hard to believe that you can play
that again please
hold on a sec I'm gonna get me my
husband I'll pass on the beer for now
says the off-camera figure who she says
is her husband how to be an actor right
no actual married couple could have an
exchange that's tilted it'd have to be
reading off cue cards complete with
intentionally bad grammar for that
patina of middle-class authenticity I'm
gonna get me a beer says the Harvard
professor fix me my Winston's I'm
hankering for a smoke
you've got to be kidding except
Elizabeth Warren isn't kidding she
expects you to believe every word of
what she says which means you're
watching someone who will say literally
anything whatever it takes in the
primaries on the Democratic side what it
takes is maximum left words pander so
that's what Warren has delivered this
season there's no issue in which he
doesn't have the most radical possible
position and for now it's working
Quinnipiac confirms that
but how will Warren's positions on the
issues play with the rest of the country
in next fall's general election let's
see on immigration Warren wants to
decriminalize all border crossings into
this country that sounds crazy to you
you are hardly alone two-thirds of the
country opposes that idea - Warren also
says she wants to abolish ice that's our
federal immigration enforcement agency
how many Americans agree with her on
that fewer than 25% agree with Elizabeth
Warren on that under her plan we'd
likely see a huge increase in illegal
immigration of course and she has told
us that every one of those foreign
nationals is entitled to completely free
health care courtesy of you how many
Americans approve of that idea well not
that many not surprisingly though more
than say they favor say race-based
reparations and that's something else
that Warren has called for sending
people tax dollars based on their skin
color is a Gen
the unpopular idea in this country but
Warren doesn't seem to care as she's
pointed out before America is so racist
we deserve it the country now where the
president is advancing environmental
racism economic racism criminal justice
racism health care racism health care
racism hmm you've got to wonder which
board teaching assistant in what
mediocre State University thought of
that phrase healthcare racism and what
it might mean Warren didn't bother to
define it of course in her world it's
self-explanatory you just add the word
racism after any category of Public
Policy and all the woke kids not in
unison Oh healthcare racism yeah man
it's systemic this country was built on
healthcare racism of course it was and
that ladies and gentlemen is why we need
Medicare for all it's a costly plan to
be sure but it's a plan that Elizabeth
Warren because she is magic being
infused with the power of her ancestral
Cherokee spirit animals can pay for
without raising taxes on you or anyone
you know or anyone you'll ever meet she
can do that she swears she can will you
raise taxes on the middle class for
paper to pay for it yes or no costs will
go up for the wealthy and for big
corporations and for hardworking
middle-class families costs will go down
hard-working middle-class families are
going to see their costs go down and all
their taxes go up well but here's the
thing here's the thing I've listened to
these answers a few times before will
middle-class taxes go up will private
insurance be eliminated what what
families have to deal with is cost total
cost that's what they have to deal with
are your costs going to a different
question how much were your tax no it's
how much your cost
it's how much families end up no that
argument but will you pay more in taxes
why don't you answer that question
because cuz this Jake said tonight's a
Republican talking point it's not a
Republican side
it's a question about where people are
going to come out economically look when
you're slingin BS in such copious volume
that even solace hacks like Chris
Matthews and Stephen Colbert winced a
little bit when you deliver it it's a
sign that's not a good sign can someone
like that really get elected president
hmm maybe it's not accidental that at
the very moment that Joe Biden's numbers
collapsed and Elizabeth Warren's numbers
rose Democrats in Washington started
talking about Ukraine
turns out impeachment is their reserve
chute it's the only one they've got